suite clovis casali notre envoyé spécial
le couvre-feu est durci était tendue dès
17h
le couvre-feu passe de 22 heures à 17
heures l'annoncé a été faite par le
maire de kiev vitali klitschko et avec
des paroles fortes tout civil qui se
trouvera dans la rue après 17h pourra
être considéré comme ce qu'ils appellent
des saboteurs des agents russes des
parachutistes des agents du
renseignement russe qui serait là en
reconnaissance pour faciliter l'entrée
des troupes russes dans kiev et dans le
centre névralgique de la capitale et ses
agents pourraient être abattus c'est ce
que disent les ukrainiens ici je peux
vous dire que depuis plusieurs jours
c'est la traque pour ces agents russes à
nos collègues de rfi en russe a été
arrêté hier tout près de maidan alors
qu'il se rendait pour faire un reportage
il a été arrêté par les forces de
l'ordre interrogé avant qu'ils se
rendent compte qu'ils étaient bien sûr
la journaliste mais d'origine russe d'où
la confusion et ils ont le prenaient
pour un agent russe car il ressemblait
un homme qui était recherché ici c'est
véritablement la traque pour ses
parachutistes ces soldats russes qui
sont en reconnaissance à kiev et qui
provoque ces combats dans les rues qu'on
entend peut-être cette nuit a été très
compliqué pour tout le monde ici à kiev
on a entendu pour la première fois dans
le centre et bien des tirs nourris et il
y a eu bien sûr aussi des détonations
des détonations qui continue où la
situation est très volatile très
compliqué c'est pour ça que le maire de
kiev a durci le couvre-feu pour être sûr
que les seules personnes qui sont dans
la rue après 17 heures sont soit des
combattants ukrainiens ou des russes il
faut les traquer vous avez rencontré des
ukrainiens quelle est leur moral
actuellement
eh bien ceux qui avaient peur ont fui la
capitale ces derniers jours et continue
bien sûr de fuir mais c'est très très
compliqué avec des routes coupées
touchées par les bombardements ou aussi
avec énormément de circulation vous
pouvez parfaitement l imagine alors les
ukrainiens qui sont restés bien soit ils
n'ont pas le choix nulle part où aller
soit ils ont trop peur de partir et donc
ils restent terrés chez eux ou dans les
abris et puis il y as et ukrainiens qui
ont pris les armes de nombreux
réservistes de nombreux volontaires qui
combattent particulièrement il
semblerait en bordure de kiev et
acquiesce et son ce sont surtout des
soldats ultra entraînés mais ce sont des
paroles à prendre avec des précautions
parce que les ukrainiens ont été appelés
à prendre les armes par le président
zelensky et par les autorités depuis le
premier jour alors vous avez des
ukrainiens qui prennent les armes pour
défendre leur maison pour défendre leur
patrie c'est l'union nationale et les
ukrainiens pour l'instant tiennent bon
face à l'assaut des russes mais
forcément beaucoup d'inquiétude beaucoup
de crainte ici à kiev de voir davantage
de troupes russes arrivés au sol merci
beaucoup clovis casali merci à vous